Hello Freak bitches,
Yo blackout and go to head to a bar.
Well,
the problem is the titles are actually waking up in the song.
I mean,
I go,
no,
here's the honestly what happened.
So I went to my buddy Dave Cobb,
he's a producer there.
I actually met him through your buddy sturgeon.
Actually,
I didn't really meet him,
but everyone,
there's a bunch of articles that said Sturge will introduce me to him.
So I'm just going with it.
Well,
it means [inaudible] narrative.
Yeah,
it helps.
But um,
so uh,
and I'd kind of been kicking around in Nashville for like about 15 years or so
and with no success at all.
I mean,
just bullshit.
And I'd been to,
had my ass kicked my dick in the dirt as they say.
And then,
um,
I was like,
fuck it,
this is going to be my last record.
I was like,
I'm going to whatever they call it,
drop the Mike put out a really fucking dirty ass record though at record.
I was wanting to make and not pull any punches.
I was going to just pay for my cell phone.
It myself.
And I had a feeling this was going to get me banned from Nashville and then I'd
just leave cause I fucking broke.
So we made this fucking dirty record and it's probably about as dirt and it's
not,
it wasn't even like I want to make the dirties country record.
It was just like,
what's happened now in Nashville,
cause it's turned into such fucking bullshit is um,
well money's happened,
right?
Well what's happened is country radio was no longer a country music.
What is it?
It's,
and I didn't know this any more new,
cause I don't listen to that dog shit,
but I,
um,
actually heard the best explanation for it the other day.
Steve Earle,
who's a hero of mine,
he was on this Chris Shifflet podcast.
I don't know if you know,
he is,
he's a guitar player for Sue Fund.
Has a good podcast where he interviews a lot of country music.
She loves country.
Oh Wow.
And Steve Earle goes,
um,
you could say,
you could hear him.
He's kind of talking around it.
He goes
country today,
you know,
mainstream corporate countries.
He goes,
it's rap music for people.
And he pauses.
He's like,
it's rap music for people and he just keep hearing him pause like,
is he going to say it?
He goes,
it's rep people for it's rap music for people who are scared of black people.
And it's true.
It does.
If it affects it a lot.
Our team,
we had this team called the Molly boys,
so that was my rectum.
Molly boys like they're all the boys are all on Molly.
All met hanging out doing Molly and what an athletic crew.
A lot of edits.
You very positive squad.
The closet of squad.
He's hugging everybody.
Give me a hug,
bro.
Yo,
we lose by 30 it's cool man.
I love books and love your pockets.
Yeah,
no,
we look like fucking clowns are jerseys had like Molly Ringwald face on him and
it said Mala,
please show me.
I want to put that shit on Lauren,
you got to fucking join the squad.
Yo Dude.
Amen.
Come on.
I think I,
I think I might even have one in the fucking backseat of my car.
Boy's
Jersey with your name all over.
We need to have that.
You're going to after the show.
You got to give me that photo and I'm going to put it on Instagram status.
Goddamn hilarious.
Yo,
my boy Bernard designed this shit.
Molly boys.
Yes.
Here it is.
Look at these jerseys.
Oh my God.
Happened to her man.
I don't,
uh,
she's been in a couple films.
I saw her in something in the news recently,
but no,
I don't know what happened,
man.
That's a weird world.
She peaked that peak,
Bro.
The eighties movie world is a weird world.
I'm surprised that people selling press pills haven't put her face on like press
pill yet.
That would,
that would sell like wildfire.
Anybody
out there and making press pills in your bathtub,
monitoring wells face on them.
I think the only thing that took me a while to get used to was so much MCT oil.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful with that though.
I text you yesterday I was running,
Matt took this,
a bunch of snow,
MCT oil.
I swear to God.
I was like,
it's Venice.
I might as well just shit my pants,
right?
Like no one's gonna give a fuck.
I will just shit everywhere.
There's a tipping point with MCT oil where it just opens a flow.
There's no,
there's no like there's no like third gear first or fucking six care man.
Where is it?
Is it like two tablespoons?
I'm trying to figure it out.
Like three tablespoons.
You're gone.
That should is the perfect storm for explosive diarrhea.
If you want it clean out the pipes,
you don't need a colonic.
Like God,
I gotta take a shit.
It's like it's coming.
You better fucking figure it out
but up and you're tensing up your in herds.
You're trying to like clamp it down to stop running.
I was like,
I better think I pick him up.
Game plan here in my mouth started watering and there's that battle that you
play.
It's very similar.
The battle when you're trying not to come,
you know the battle when you try not to come loose,
just squeezing it.
Dickish it is.
It's very similar to that.
I don't want to shit my pants.
Pow.
You have willpower.
Cause there's some weak people in the world that just shit their pants more than
they shut.
You can't be my friend if you,
if you just give up and shit your pants loose.
Fun.
Keep my butt tight.
You just got no will power man.
Yeah,
but then I've Shit my pants before too.
It's like here's the deal.
It's okay to tap out.
Just don't tap out like a bitch.
Not at least put up a fight.
Going to lose the fight.
Be actually in a position where you have to tap.
You just tap cause you're sweating and it's just,
you have no other option.
He Calvin lighty one time,
said he shit his pants and then showed up with regular beds.
Well that's one I just can't do.
He said that he couldn't make it to the show at the ice house.
I looked at the,
because he shit his pants and I said,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
I shit my pants.
I can't come.
I said,
Brian,
these people came to see you.
They're here to see you.
And he goes,
what should I do?
I go,
go to a fucking bathroom at a gas station,
take your fucking pants off,
throw them in the sink,
clean the shit out of your pants,
wring them out,
and they get over here with wet pants on and a story.
How old is he at this time?
Oh,
like a year ago.
This is years ago.
What should I do?
You got to show up,
man.
You got to show up.
Like people don't want to smell shit on you,
so if you could just get to the bathroom for five minutes,
you can fix all that.
It's going to take a little work and you get to wear wet pants,
but that's what you have to do.
Duty paid paid the there.
Brian Cowen fans I think will fuck you up,
dude.
Hanging out your pants.
Tell some jokes.
So he shows up.
10 minutes later his pants were dry and I go,
what happened?
And he said,
oh,
I had a pair of pants in my trunk.
The worst slide I see a pair of pants or your trunk.
I don't know what.
I didn't even want to ask what was really going on?
Get into it.
You Shit your pants as a grown man.
I mean,
it ain't a simple procedure.
There's some steps you got to me.
That's the next next shirt is I had another pair of pants in my truck carries
pants in the trunk.
Have you ever had a pair of pants in your trunk and you didn't know about?
Never Shit your pants and go.
What is the odds that the pants are my trunk?
Never.
I guess when I'm older I might,
I might have a baseball hat in there.
I can cover my balls.
I love that story.
Kind of all the lies.
Shitting your pants.
I don't know.
I'm gonna need,
I'm gonna need to see some stuff.
I do not know if it was a lie,
but Goddamn,
he smelled so normal.
I mean,
I would just only calendar.
It's the best.
It's the only she could do that.
There's only so much you can learn from people.
You know?
At a certain point,
you have to understand that what makes them special is because it's stem.
It comes out of them.
You can't learn that.
You can't really take it,
but what'd you can take is the feeling of they had their own identity and you've
got to find that in yourself.
That's the thing that you want to ultimately get.
You know what I mean?
You want to be influenced by all these people,
but the main influence that I think you should learn from the greats or that
you,
you have to find it in yourself.
You know,
you can't rely on it anybody else.
Right.
And I think to see it in someone else gives you that inspiration to try to find
it in yourself.
So I used to search for it,
just constantly going to be at the library,
getting up VHS,
you know,
videos and just watching,
rewinding and watching.
And then I would drive 19 hours from Akron to Mississippi just to like maybe
find a musician who I heard lived in some town.
You know what I mean?
Just because I wanted to see it,
you know?
And,
and when I find,
when I found it,
this shit is life changing,
man.
I mean,
I was like 17 and I went to Greenville,
Mississippi,
and I just started asking around for this musician named,
his name was t model Ford and he made some really cool team model Ford.
Yeah.
He was total bad ass.
He played a death metal guitar,
like really a Pv.
Yeah.
And it said with the letters who put on a mailbox,
it's like said team motto for the Tail Dragger he had it spray painted on his
trailer that he pulled around with his Lincoln and I,
wow.
Just go on there.
I would never want to just like become that person.
Right.
But
whether they're from Mississippi or they're like a classical composer from
Germany,
there's a thing that these all these guys have in common.
And it's like a sense of self,
you know what I mean?
Anybody I've ever met has a real,
just a confidence that,
you know,
even though they may not be the best at certain things,
they can like bring out the best in themselves,
you know,
and that,
and that's like enough.
Do you know what I mean?
[inaudible].